a highly anticipated debut in Munich
Mike Pence's first speech in Germany as
US Vice President was closely watched by
nervous European partners he opened with
a message of reassurance the United
States of America strongly supports NATO
and will be unwavering in our commitment
to this transatlantic alliance pense
also reiterated a call for NATO partners
to step up their spending on defense the
President of the United States expects
our allies to keep their word to fulfill
this commitment and foremost that means
the time has come to do more to its just
waking earlier Chancellor Angela Merkel
told the conference that Germany was
ready to share the burden like all the
other member countries at the NATO
conference in Wales in 2014 Germany
committed to hitting the two percent
target within 10 years I'll echo our
defense minister in saying will make
every effort we are committed to that
target Germany currently only spends
around 1.2 percent of its gdp on defense
despite the urgings from the Trump
administration Merkel dampened
expectations at building would hit two
percent anytime soon but Angela Merkel
speech was welcomed by NATO's top
official NATO secretary-general yen
stoltenberg praised the German
Chancellor's commitment as a vital
contribution to European freedom peace
and security